well overseas US forces in Syria caught
in the middle of growing diplomatic
tensions between Turkey in the United
States turkey said this morning it will
launch an offensive against US allies in
Syria whether or not the Trump
administration delays the promised
withdrawal of troops the diplomatic
battle has not changed the mission of
those protecting American forces on the
ground Charlie d'Agata met with US
service members on board an aircraft
carrier recently redeployed to the
recent region they don't do government
shutdowns on US aircraft carriers in the
Persian Gulf
we arrived aboard the u.s. as Johnson
Stennis to find the nuclear-powered
supercarriers pull steam catapulting
f-18 fighter jets into the sky they've
hit Taliban targets in Afghanistan and
continue to launch dozens of airstrikes
against Isis positions in Iraq and yes
Syria
whatever the mixed messages out of
Washington despite president Trump's
abrupt decision to withdraw US forces
from Syria here at least there's been no
let-up in the number of aircraft sent
out to support them and in support of
their Kurdish allies on the ground
despite continued threats from Turkey
then there's Iran the return of a US
aircraft carrier has angered Iranian
officials who deployed naval vessels to
shadow the Strike Group after it arrived
from its home port of Bremerton
Washington last month captain Randy Peck
is the commanding officer I would call
welcome to wagging to the neighborhood
and did you see them oh sure they were
you know they were they were escorting
us through the Straits of Hormuz it
might be a safe way to say it the Strait
of Hormuz maybe an international transit
route but it passes right through
Iranian territorial waters and few
military set-pieces project u.s. power
more than a carrier group it takes 5,000
people to have one pilot go off the
pointy end of the ship to achieve the
nation's objective when everybody knows
that and they're firing on that easy day
Bruce CBS this morning Charlie d'Agata
aboard
USS John C Stennis in the Persian Gulf